[SPEAKER_01]: Second of Wales, son, after the sun has set... We were able to get a rest in here, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: The party, resting and communicating with the barracks for about an hour, trying to figure out what their next moves are.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, there was communication from the barracks, obviously from Jude, correct?
[SPEAKER_04]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: You communicate back and forth using the mirrors and light, basically the lantern signals, and what you find out is that Jude and Paul Rivera are in the garrison.
[SPEAKER_01]: The garrison is controlled by the sea principalities.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are 150 men there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, they're waiting for you if you want to come and deal with them.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's some urgency at this point in time associated with the fact that the island, which is surrounded by sahagin, cannot get reinforcements until they're driven away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Jude says he has a plan to do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, trust the little elf, he's pretty smart.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd say our plan is...
[SPEAKER_02]: You and I, we're going out ahead and we're bringing these two with us and I think three swords and two bowmen or two bowmen and three swords.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that's what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then the sergeant, is that what he was?
[SPEAKER_02]: The sergeant is holding back here with the other men and make sure
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't get flanked from behind or anything from the ones that are in the other.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also, basically what he said is any boats that are sailing this way, he will signal them and say, don't come.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we have enough so that we can signal back whatever we need to signal back to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm asking the Bard, do we have what we need to signal back to him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, what you have is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not taking anything with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: When you get to the barracks, you can signal back.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you're not going to take the lantern that signals there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think I'm five down still after the short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would that be correct?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, because I'm using the new sheet you updated here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, what I will ask...
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that the Paladin picked the spells that he's going to have?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, I have them marked.
[SPEAKER_00]: You do?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, these ones are already...
[SPEAKER_00]: I've got...
[SPEAKER_00]: So you get to pick four.
[SPEAKER_00]: Compelled Duel, Cure Wounds,
[SPEAKER_00]: Searing Smite and Thunderous Smite.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you always have Divine Smite?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, the ones that are... That's a question.
[SPEAKER_00]: So these ones, are these in addition to, or do they count as... Those are always ones you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the third-level ones, which are Compel Duel and Command, you always have.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if you picked Compel Duel...
[SPEAKER_01]: I need to pick a different one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Pick a different one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, then I will pick Shield of Faith.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it's the original.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you finish communicating with them around 10pm.
[SPEAKER_01]: At what point in time do you want to try and sneak off?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm saying as soon as possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: Once nightfall and it's a clear night too.
[SPEAKER_04]: I mean, we're going no matter what.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And if you decide that they were going to
[SPEAKER_00]: The tower archers were going to, our archers in the, where they're at, they were gonna kind of cover our tree to create a diversion sometimes?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, they were gonna go out forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, we were gonna go out this way.
[SPEAKER_00]: We were gonna go out the back.
[SPEAKER_00]: But they were gonna go on the top and shoot at the barracks that was there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Creating an aversion while we take off at least so we're out of harm's way from them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're taking with you two crossbowmen and three soldiers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I do believe that is correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, your party collects at the back of the tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the marching order?
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's going to go first?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to go first because I know the terrain, I know the island first, and then Gouge is going to follow behind me, kind of, not at a distance, but... Keep you in sight?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to scout now.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I can be stealthy if I...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll keep Gouge in sight and then everybody else can be behind me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll follow behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you should be within the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you go out first, and you go out the back of the tower, and...
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically start trying to go make it towards the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're stealthy.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's your stealth?
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus five.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell me what you get.
[SPEAKER_01]: Turkey.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: He goes into the night and becomes dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically knowing the contours of the coastline like no one else, hiding in the grass.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically just becoming one with the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even though there's a moon, it's almost like the shadows he knows as well as he knows the dunes.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you move forward 30 feet, just completely silent.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far away do you want to go before you signal your party to come?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to try to cross the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, well you make it to the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're about 150 feet away at this point.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see no one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll a perception check.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a 20, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: 12.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus...
[SPEAKER_01]: Put your perception on there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus 6.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You see no one on the other side of the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's very clear.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are shadows in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know they're there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But at least up to the bridge, there's no one between the tower and there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I'm going to signal for you guys to come up behind me, so... Oh, shit, there he is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Damn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you basically signal the men to sneak forward, and you guys start going forward?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I signal Ty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, he's in control of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to keep in between him and still lead on him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you start sneaking forward towards the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll your stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-seven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge, sneaks into the moonlight and disappears.
[SPEAKER_01]: Awesome.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you follow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go, boys.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's your self?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's at the bottom.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus two.
[SPEAKER_00]: You need the magnifying glass.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine, ten, eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine, ten, eleven?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear his footsteps behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it's not as horrible as the clanking of scale mail against scale mail.
[SPEAKER_01]: Luckily he has his breastplate on, so you think that the glinting moonlight may be mistaken for, I don't know, water reflections or something like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: He'd never make it in the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_01]: You follow?
[SPEAKER_01]: I follow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thirteen, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bard follows, and then your guys follow as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the crossbowmen.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, roll another one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll two for the swordsmen, and there are three guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: So roll two dice for them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eights.
[SPEAKER_01]: One guy gets eights.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll the other one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine is seven, so it's a seven, and then roll the last.
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six, and one more die.
[SPEAKER_01]: Twelve.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: You move forward, Tyrus, and the sound of your men behind you is horrible to hear.
[SPEAKER_01]: The clanking of the scale mail is awful, and they trip and basically not find their way in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_01]: They give you away.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh shit, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so, roll an ish.
[SPEAKER_01]: You roll.
[SPEAKER_00]: Eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You hear the sound of crossbow bolts firing in your direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: First one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Misses your first guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Misses that guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Miss.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, three bolts are firing in your direction.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can tell that your men are...
[SPEAKER_01]: Not seen, but they're heard.
[SPEAKER_01]: But they're definitely firing on your five guys that are falling behind you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What about the guys at the top?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are they firing down?
[SPEAKER_00]: They start firing down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Many arrows down below.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to order them to do anything, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to tell them to go back.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to tell them to go back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I cast Fog Cloud right now, too?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you'd like, on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, I mean, that's going to use the spell slot.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I'm going to do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to create the Diversion?
[SPEAKER_04]: So they don't see, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to cast Fog Cloud behind us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so use one first level spell slot, and do you want to cast it in the area that they are?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or do you want to cast it on yourself?
[SPEAKER_01]: You're at the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, what's the range of?
[SPEAKER_01]: 120 feet, I can cast it.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can do it on the area, definitely.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you cast a spell, spell slots second level are higher.
[SPEAKER_04]: The radius of the fog increases by 20 feet for each... Oh, I'm not there by you to... You can't do that, but if you want to cast it where they are, you can.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, it's 25 radius.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I want to cast it behind me.
[SPEAKER_04]: For them two to keep moving forward and the guards to move back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to cast it on the guards so they can get away or do you want to cast it in the area where your friends are moving?
[SPEAKER_04]: Friends are... Have they been detected?
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: In fact, what you see is the people getting fired on are the...
[SPEAKER_01]: Guy's wearing a scale male.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Basically, because they're making sound.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yep, I'm casting it behind me on the guards to keep moving back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you put up a fog cloud using a spell slot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Next round, and you tell your man basically, go back!
[SPEAKER_01]: Go back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so the five-minute arms do what you say and return back to the
[SPEAKER_01]: The tower.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, three of you catch up to where Merrick is and get to the bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: The four of you are alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we're at the edge of the bridge.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's go.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want to look over the bridge and I want to check if there's any sharks I can see in the water or shark men.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you look down into the waters below.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Role perception.
[SPEAKER_04]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_01]: Plus six.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are sharks.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you see a sahuagin riding a shark in the water off to this way in the bay.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So what we need to do to get across this bridge, we need to go center of the bridge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do not go near the edges of the bridge.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to go right down the center.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think we need to go as quiet as we can, so we should go one at a time.
[SPEAKER_04]: We shouldn't travel as a group, per se.
[SPEAKER_04]: We should have some distance between each other, and we'll gather on the other side of the bridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, you two, twos?
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll go in twos.
[SPEAKER_00]: You two, the rest two?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, me and Gouge will go, and then you two will follow.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, sound good?
[SPEAKER_04]: Sneak across.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so with your weapons out, you with your bow, you with your cutlass and dagger, you sneak across the bridge in the center, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Exposed in the moonlight, but fortunately protected from view on either side here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You cross.
[SPEAKER_01]: The bridge is probably around, I would say, 400 feet and you get to the other side.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh shit, okay, it's a ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's a big bridge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, as soon as you're to the other side, we're going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, the two of you cross.
[SPEAKER_01]: Again, neither of you are molested as you get across, but you definitely feel exposed as you get to there.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the two of you are waiting for them, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: You get up to their side of the bridge and the four of you collect on that side.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we're getting signals from Garrison, not Helm.
[SPEAKER_04]: So what we're gonna do, we're not gonna travel
[SPEAKER_04]: On the coastline.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're going to stay as far away from that as possible.
[SPEAKER_04]: We need to go through the most wooded, secluded area.
[SPEAKER_04]: It might take us a little bit longer instead of a straight shot, but we need to go through the trees and brush as much as we can.
[SPEAKER_02]: You lead the path.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: I trust in that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so you're going to cut across to the forest?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you're going to be how far into the forest as you walk?
[SPEAKER_01]: I assume it's the edge.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm getting to the edge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you're stealthing, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Stealthing, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, you stealth along the edge of the forest.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I would say the entire distance from there to the barracks is probably half a mile.
[SPEAKER_01]: But because you're stealthing, it's going to take you about an hour to do this distance, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And you're not on the...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's kind of a road.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's really a path, a dirt path that goes there.
[SPEAKER_01]: But you go through the sparse woods, palm trees, stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a little circuitous, but not horrible.
[SPEAKER_01]: And probably in about an hour, around 11 p.m., you find yourself
[SPEAKER_01]: 60 feet, 70 feet outside the Palisade walls of the barracks, you see towers with marines standing on them at guard.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: So we're both there.
[SPEAKER_01]: All of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, they obviously see us.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, they don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys are stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're in the woods.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need a signal to them so that we don't get, we need a signal to them to get in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does anybody know this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there only one door to this?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where's the entrance?
[SPEAKER_01]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the only entrance?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if I remember correctly, there was stuff going off and everything when they went right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was stuff going off on the docks.
[SPEAKER_04]: On the docks, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, but here, no.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge and I, Gouge, do you want to go up to the wall and try to get to the door?
[SPEAKER_04]: Kind of ride, sneak along the wall?
[SPEAKER_02]: This isn't, I can't, can you climb up and go in or is this all solid?
[SPEAKER_01]: You could try and scale the Palisades, but you might be seen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, there are people, garrisons, like, along there.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's 150 men, so that's all around.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, in the towers there are like maybe two.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not like you see all 150.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right, right, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but they're all spread out, so there's people kind of everywhere watching.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think we need to sneak in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I don't care if they see us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think they're expecting us, because we've been signaling the whole time.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's obvious they're men, and it's obvious they're Iridians.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, they're not hobgoblins, basically, is what I'm trying to say to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: We should try to pursue the front door.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to try to scale it?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think we can just call out from right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're close.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know if we should call out in the wilderness like this.
[SPEAKER_03]: How far away are we from the tower?
[SPEAKER_03]: 70 feet from the walls.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's about 30 feet from the forest to the walls.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a clearing of 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far does message go?
[SPEAKER_01]: 120 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to try to sneak up.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're expecting us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I can sneak up and try to go around the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if anyone's exposed, it's me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can aware them with message.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can whisper to one of them up there to let us in and to announce our arrival.
[SPEAKER_03]: Therefore, we don't have to like... Oh, so you can do something to do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Say we're here at the edge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Look over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it clear to go in?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm gonna cast message at one of the men on the tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just gonna say...
[SPEAKER_03]: There's four of us.
[SPEAKER_03]: We were the ones you were signaling towards.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge and party are here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge and party is here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Near the edge of the woods.
[SPEAKER_01]: Using the power of your message, he's able to speak back to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're expecting you, and we've been on the lookout.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go along the west wall to the front gate, and you'll be led in.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Still weapons out, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's move.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's ride the wall.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you run to the wall, and then go around it to the front gate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_01]: And very soon, as soon as you get to the front, they lift it up, and the four of you slip underneath into the area.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, standing there in front is a...
[SPEAKER_01]: A sergeant wearing a breastplate, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And he's like, ah, Merrick, it is good to see you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tyrus, you know this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is one of Fairfield's, not Fairfield's, but Fairwind's sergeants.
[SPEAKER_01]: We've heard of your coming.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is good that you've been able to come.
[SPEAKER_00]: Awesome to see you, Steve.
[SPEAKER_00]: How fair is the garrison to the south?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we have a small group of men there that are holding it.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have... What about the 20 men stationed in the lighthouse?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's nobody in the lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: We own the lighthouse, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our ship was able to get the lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: The barracks is full of sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the hobgoblins are dead, but the barracks is full of sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought there were hobgoblins in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: There are hobgoblins in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: The hobgoblins are in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Several men, I don't know exactly how many, at least...
[SPEAKER_00]: 10, 15.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we own the, not the lighthouse, the keep.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know about the lighthouse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Tower, we have the tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have the tower, that's what I'm trying to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's men in the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll signal any ships that it's unsafe.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so we own that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But the lighthouse and the barracks are in Hobgoblin.
[SPEAKER_04]: How many men did you lose coming up from the, we saw the ship get overran by sahuagin?
[SPEAKER_01]: We've lost no men and actually the unit that was
[SPEAKER_01]: Escorting Paul, Rivero, lost no men either.
[SPEAKER_01]: They were able to get here unmolested.
[SPEAKER_01]: The entire contingent on the ship, however, was lost.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something like 200 men, I believe.
[SPEAKER_02]: No survivors.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: I look for the elf.
[SPEAKER_02]: You look around?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, just to see if the elf's down here.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's not standing there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Didn't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: The sergeant goes...
[SPEAKER_01]: He looks at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kind of shakes his head.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Steve.
[SPEAKER_01]: Ah, Steve.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsum.
[SPEAKER_01]: You must be Gouge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Indeed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Rivero and his attendant wish to speak with you.
[SPEAKER_01]: They wish to speak with you all, actually.
[SPEAKER_01]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright, so he leads you down into the barracks to what you assume to be the office.
[SPEAKER_01]: The main office.
[SPEAKER_01]: The command center.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he leads you into this room where the young prince, Paul Rivero, is sitting.
[SPEAKER_01]: No sign of Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul, I think I've said, is strange.
[SPEAKER_01]: He wears this mask, this silver mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: In person, it's even stranger.
[SPEAKER_01]: He basically is wearing that mask still, and all his clothing, leather clothing, is very tight-fitting, and he's wearing gloves, even in this hot weather.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's very bizarre.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The four of you file in, and Paul is in.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll be right back.